قامت القوات الروسية بزرع حقول
ألغام كثيفة ونشرت
عددًا كبيرًا من قوات الاحتياط على طول
الجبهة الجنوبية، وهذا وفقًا لقائد
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية الجنرال
فاليري زالوشني، مما يؤكد مدى
صعوبة الهجوم المضاد الذي تشنه أوكرانيا والذي لا يزال
في مراحله الأولى
صباح يوم الاثنين.
أعلن نائب وزير الدفاع الأوكراني أن
قوات كييف تمكنت من استعادة
ثماني مستوطنات و113
كيلومترًا مربعًا أو حوالي 44 ميلًا مربعًا من
الأراضي، ولكن بحلول فترة ما بعد الظهر لم يكن من
الواضح على الإطلاق أي جانب، إن وجد، كان
يسيطر على إحدى تلك المستوطنات الثمانية.
المستوطنات بلدة بياتيهاتكي جنوب
زابور الآن، مضى على
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني أقل من أسبوعين،
ويُعتقد على نطاق واسع أن
الأوكرانيين لم يرسلوا بعد الجزء الأكبر
من قواتهم للقتال، حيث
يبدو أن الروس قد كشفوا عن
تكتيك جديد للحشو.  دبابة قديمة من طراز T-54 من الحقبة السوفيتية
محملة بأطنان من المتفجرات وتقودها
بدون طيار نحو الخطوط الأوكرانية، وقد
نشرت وزارة الدفاع الروسية الآن مقطع
فيديو يظهر تلك الدبابة وهي تنطلق في
انفجار هائل على بعد 300 ياردة فقط من
الخطوط الأوكرانية، لكن ليس من الواضح ما
إذا كانت  تسبب الانفجار في وقوع أي إصابات،
أنا بن ويتمان أبلغ شبكة سي إن إن من
زابور